for most of her life isabelle has been
severely disabled
she can't walk can barely talk and has
no means of caring for herself
but it's the last 18 months of this 18
year old's life that have been some of
the most difficult
the covered pandemic has just made
everything a hundred million times worse
because
we had we went from having carers in the
morning from seven
to all the children being out of school
to over one weekend having no had no
support no help nothing
but their ordeal is no surprise new
research from the leading think tank for
the north of england highlighted a
number of injustices disabled people
here are faced with it tells a story of
a region being failed on access to vital
services
we've got local governments local
authorities
that are increasingly cash strapped and
they're struggling to make really
difficult decisions about about budgets
and what services that they can provide
in terms of social care for people
and this is we know this is particularly
the case in the north of england we
really need to make sure that disabled
people are at the heart of any strategy
because otherwise it's just not going to
work the report revealed social care
funding per disabled person in the north
is over 2
700 pounds lower than england as a whole
it found disabled northerners have some
of the lowest levels of happiness and
highest levels of anxiety in the country
and during the pandemic people with
disabilities in the region were less
likely to be employed than the national
average
responding to the findings the
government told us throughout the
pandemic we have been working with the
social care sector to ensure all
recipients of care receive the support
they need we are committed to reforming
the adult social care system and will
bring forward proposals later this year
elizabeth said she hadn't noticed the
disparities up until now but seeing them
in black and white she believes it's
shocking it makes me feel
a mixture of sad and angry um that if we
lived somewhere else in the country
we would be able to get additional help
and support for for me and isabel and my
other children whereas we have to
survive almost on what we've got at the
minute
it's just
not leveling up is it
there is no doubt the pandemic in some
way has shaped all of our lives but for
isabelle her mother and many thousands
in the north of the country
life has been a little bit tougher
insane rasheed sky news manchester